I like Katie because he's the kind of
guy he'll DM you if if you say some wild
[ __ ] to him like uh Andrew Schultz my
homie he's a comedian he says some [ __ ]
about him online and this will DM them
like what he says I'm like in the
comments
yeah but then he I hit shows I say hey
yo look at what what uh Katie said he's
bro you just DM me so I'm like say that
[ __ ] to my face type she didn't see me
like bro you're a billionaire Katie get
all [ __ ] ass I'll be I'll be wanting
to do this [ __ ] sometime so I'd be like
hey I ain't the one I I get your IP
address little bro yeah people don't
even know about that how do you get
someone's IP address
you have a [ __ ] Tech Team
just send the Twitter I don't know you
know that might be if if you ever did
retire from rapping you could start a
YouTube channel where you just pull up
on internet gang bangers on the keyboard
gangsters houses and just surprise them
not even do nothing just surprises nah
do you like pay attention to comments
and [ __ ] do you let that [ __ ] like get
to you or do you just like is it out of
sight out of mind type [ __ ]
I'm human bro like I ain't gonna say get
to me but
I owned it I don't I don't know I'm just
I don't play this [ __ ] I don't let
nobody just say anything I ain't gonna I
might not say nothing but I'm gonna take
heed to it like yeah I might screenshot
what you said like screenshot your
picture or something like you know what
I'm saying other than it I ain't gonna
say nothing to you yeah I feel like
people who say like oh the comments
don't bother me it's like even if you
don't think they bother you
subconsciously you kind of take that
[ __ ] in yeah yeah
like you might you might not like let
people know what [ __ ] with you but like
come on anytime someone says I ain't
gonna say like it no it's not but I'm
saying but like you said you take note
of it
to it for sure yeah what's the wildest
[ __ ] like uh like just someone's like
said some wild [ __ ] to you like is it in
the DMS do they hit you with some crazy
[ __ ] is it just talking [ __ ] about music
like what is it
I'll see I don't I don't know I ain't
never just I don't just take my DMs to
my like that to be
you're DMV I'm trying to see like with
my comments yeah
they say all type of [ __ ] I don't know
just like yeah well you see what Drake
did he he uh someone talked [ __ ] and he
uh DM the dude's girl
he sliding and he found the guy's
profile it's something I do but he found
it I ain't like that no more yeah so you
would you would in the past you might do
that
I would do that
just hit it like yo [ __ ] you I'm a [ __ ]
your chick yeah it's me that's great
yeah do you make sure they know that you
[ __ ] their girl
I'll make sure they know I ain't I ain't
talked to like Billy like that I don't
it's just good enough for you to know
that I [ __ ] the haters girl yeah